yeah 100 I kept making Partnerships with
people that I shouldn't have gotten into
Partnerships with I have nine failed
Partnerships and it was because I didn't
understand the only reason to partner
with somebody is that they either have
money you don't have time you don't have
or experience you don't have if somebody
else is just somebody you like you're
friends with them whatever it is like
those are typically not good reasons to
be in business because if both of you
are the same then one of you is not
required in every business from an
operational perspective you've got three
legs of the stool you've got the
operator in terms of the person who's
running the day-to-day business you've
got the promoter the person who's going
to be looking at marketing and sales
then you've got the person who's
delivering product in the beginning
sometimes that's you with multiple hats
on but those are kind of the Three core
functions of the business those are the
different kind of puzzle pieces that you
have to think okay of those things which
is in my current skill set and which am
I lacking and you'd be seeking out
people who have the things that you
don't